[Musique]
tous mes copains quand je les vois
passer tous mes copains sont à
moi tous mes copains je les ai
embrassé tous mes
maime
[Musique]
bien tous mes copains il faut bien les
aimer
tous mes copains savent
bien tous mes copains ont le jour et la
nuit tous mes copains m'aiment
bien
l'armée me les
emmène par les quatre
chemins la nuit me les
ramène sans attendre
demain certains ne viendront plus
certains sont
revenus ils vont se
marier et je ne les vois
plus tous mes copains s'en vont main
dans la
main tous mes copains s'en
iront tous mes copains
reprendront le
chemin tous mes copains sont
[Musique]
partis
[Applaudissements]
tous mes copains
reprendront le
chemin tous mes copains sont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partis
[Musique]